oh I'm so excited for this episode yeah
Kenny I don't think I'm right into your
father but you already got some awesome
apparel chekura would your collection
guys it's almost sold out at our online
store you can look like this or this or
this or this and even this
go to human good la comm and check out
this amazing apparel enjoy the episode
guys I asked my partner to consider
having an abortion
I was excited when I found out I was
going to be a dad
3 2 1 go being a daddy was a mix of
excitement and you know just it was a
little scared you know you know it
changes your whole life forever I mean
everything about your life just flips
upside down I planned my pregnancy I
plan my baby when I was little I would
always take care of my little brothers
my little sister and my parents would be
working my mom would be working my
parents obviously going together yeah I
feel like I'm I've been ready as a young
age and I've always wanted to have a kid
at a really young age I don't know why
but it's just I knew I wanted to be a
father for me I was really excited
because my girlfriend already had a baby
so we weren't trying to get pregnant so
the debt so the moment I saw the
positive on the pregnancy test I was
pretty excited but obviously everyone's
nervous the day that we found out about
the pregnancy was three days before I
left for college and so it really wasn't
positive at first because I was just
scared about what was gonna happen with
me going to college and like what our
plans were for the future because
nothing seemed to like fit we had a
certain way that it looked like it was
going to be going and then it all just
kind of changed
instantly my family approves of me
having a child at my age 3 2 1 go
my family is actually very excited and
they were the first people we told cuz
we were kind of too scared to tell
anyone else at the time my mom had my
older brother at a very young age and I
don't know I've just always been able to
connect with kids yeah so just like you
guys my AK Mountain mom and dad actually
had me at a young age too but I think
for me it was harder to tell them
because they worked so hard you know to
prevent me from going on that same path
as them you know they I worked multiple
jobs and just for me and my sister and
it was the hardest telling her because I
didn't want her to feel like she failed
yeah she done so much for me and allowed
me to get a good education go to
university but in the end I still repeat
the same mistake so it was definitely
hard telling her when I told my dad that
Laura was pregnant
we weren't talking actually like he had
kicked me out of the house and I had to
talk to him for a couple months and I
text him and I was like you know you
you're gonna be that grandpa that's not
around and I think I think that really
woke him up and he came around and
supported me my mom and me you know
we're like the same person
mentally so she knew it was gonna happen
you know I asked her to go out to
breakfast on my birthday I'm gonna fold
out the pregnancy test shoes I got
[ __ ] knew it
me and my mom we had a really strong
connection to when I was young well when
I was in school and you know living
under her roof but I guess like once she
found out about the pregnancy I expected
her to be very excited but once I saw
her reaction like it's just you know
like that same morning she saying no if
you ever bring me a kid you know you're
gonna get out of here you're gonna do
your own thing you're gonna find your
own way now like I kind of feel bad but
like my kids not really around my mom my
family was not very supportive
definitely at first but as time went
along and as the babies were here and
everything they became more okay with it
it was just that they had big plans for
me my parents and they wanted me to go
to four years of college and get a
degree and then maybe continue on and
they saw this as something that would
kind of derail that plan and change it I
was educated on birth control methods
before becoming sexually active three
two one go see when you see birth
control I think of it more like towards
the women's part because I know towards
the guys it's just condoms that's it I
didn't really know much about it I
didn't know how to use one you know it's
you have to learn on your own I can say
that I learned all that once I got with
my wife once we already had our kid
that's when I already knew about the
whole birth control and all that stuff
me and my wife definitely knew about all
of them I just don't I just don't think
that we cared very much if we did get
pregnant so we didn't really use them
you know so yeah you know we knew about
condoms and she was on the pill but then
she stopped taking the pill and you know
just went from there you know the only
class I ever took was in middle school
just for one class it wasn't even for
like even a month it was just for a week
I asked my partner to consider having an
abortion three two one go
if you knew what you were getting
yourself into by having relations or you
knew what could have came from that you
shouldn't consider abortion or you can
you shouldn't consider it as one of your
options if you know what you're doing
and you know the risk you're gonna take
I feel like you should just you know
stick through it personally I have
nothing against abortion but in my case
you know it was something that it was a
choice that I couldn't live with you
know I think that life itself is
precious you have to consider all of our
options I mean if I'm gonna bring my
child into this world I want them I
don't want them to be basically just
behind at the get-go you know I don't
want them to be born into a household
where I can't you know pay to feed them
I don't know like you know if we're
gonna do this we need to be fully
committed we need to be ready to give
all your attention goes from you to to
them if you change your mindset to to
working hard and you you put yourself
down the right path you can definitely
make anything happen yeah they might
come in behind like you said but you can
always get them ahead at the time that
we found out like I was about to go to
college I was like moving away from home
and my girlfriend had had plans to go to
college and leave the state and travel
and do all these things and so I talked
to her about abortion and adoption about
other options like what we might choose
to do because it was just a stressful
time trying to figure out like what
we're gonna do for money before we
either of us had any college education
or anything I have a good relationship
with the mother of my child 3 2 1
i'ma say that I have a good relationship
with mother my child cuz one we're
married
we still got bumps in the road now you
know moving all the way across the
country away from her family but I think
that especially now before going on any
deployments or anything like that is the
time to make it stronger and I think I
think that's what we're doing I had
moved in with my baby's mom and it was a
very stressful time because we had just
gone from having zero babies obviously
to having two little infants we broke up
after a little bit and we're working on
our relationship now we have select
times that each of us will like watch
them like I watch them while she goes to
school and each person gets their own
time to do what they want to do instead
of just being surrounded by babies 24/7
I considered not being a part of my
child's life 3 2 1 go I think that's the
shittiest thing you can do just first of
all get get somebody pregnant and you
know per-say ruined their future you
know if they had if they had something
planned like college or you know
something like that but to not only ruin
her life
but then the life that you caused I
think that that's some shitty thing yeah
as soon as I found out that my
girlfriend was pregnant I quit football
right away you know I wanted to spend
all my all my time that I have towards
her because I I don't want to be doing
it alone like he said if you create life
then you should be a part of that baby's
life and that kid's life growing up
whether or not you're with the mother I
just feel like the kid deserves that
that follow the fatherly figure in their
life and you see so many fathers who
come back to that child's life and you
know it they that child doesn't want to
see them no more cause like where have
you been this whole time you know and
you know I don't want to feel that pain
like I almost hurt a lot you know just
wanted to see your child that you
weren't there for in the beginning so
you know not only that but you know even
if they do want
you don't know what they like so you
take them to get pizza or spaghetti or
something and they're like I don't like
this I think that would suck
I knew that I liked need it to be in my
kid's life and my kids needed me in my
life but it was just difficult in the
beginning because I didn't have many
influences or people saying that it's a
good idea pretty much everyone around me
was saying like it's a bad idea or like
it's bad other than the baby's mother
and so it was a really hard time but I
knew that I needed to be there for them
I am able to financially support my
child 3 2 1 for me I'm very very
thankful for the opportunity that we
have in a YouTube channel because we
have that revenue to where we can make
even a savings account for our children
the path I chose like I want to go to
law school and that's a lot more years
like I won't be able to financially
support a child for a little while so
without the help of you know my family
and my girlfriend's family you know I
want to be able to be doing this yeah
for me I mean I was working at it I am
still working at a church but only one
day out of the week so I felt like that
wasn't enough you know but now I'm
working two part-time jobs but yes in
the beginning it was difficult and that
it just feels horrible like your mother
having to pay for diapers or white bees
when you gotta get money from other
people but not I'm just trying to make
money however I can yeah raising a child
that's a whole job in itself you know so
trying to go to school on top of that
work go to school raise a child you know
you're doing military YouTube oh it's
it's really it's time-consuming yeah and
you want to spend like all the time you
have with your kids but you being away
it's hard yeah you really have to make
sacrifices somewhere you know to be
financially stable or you know to get
the things you want part of those
sacrifices is losing time with their
family yeah this Friday I got invited to
like a senior party you know just senior
since no like that you know the
temptations that you want to have fun
but you know I write I instead of doing
that I had dinner with my family
and then you know now that I think of it
wait
no I feel judged by others for being a
team dad 3 2 1 go I don't focus on the
negativity like I'm always positive but
a lot of my friends in in football you
know they judge me
oh you got you know they will call my
girlfriend names you know you you got
that [ __ ] pregnant or you got you know
this and that but I noticed that those
friends weren't even friends at all you
know they're making a joke out of me but
I didn't let it get to me you know I
know what is most important and that is
um you know being there for my family
ever since I was a kid they I would
always hear you need to go to college
you need to go to school you need to
finish school you need to get a job this
and this and that and it sucks because
you know like you wanna you want to be
able to prove them that you can do it
that you're gonna be able to graduate
and I know like I can still do it
no matter what but it's I know that I'm
also getting judged from some of them
some of my family members some of my
friend you know I'll be in class and
I'll meet new people and we're like oh
let's go to a study session like oh no I
can't I got to go back home and go back
with my kid and I kind of look at me
like oh like you have a kid like Otis
like when is he gonna drop out or when
he's there's a lot of stereotypes with
that like you know it changes minds he
asked do you guys feel judged and I
think the main word that stuck out to me
was feel and I don't really care what
people think so I don't really feel
anything about what they say like you
know if we're like the store or
something and people are staring I just
stare right back like [ __ ] you staring
at and then just walk away cuz I mean
what are they gonna do this is gonna
impact my life nothing because I'm doing
something that's impacting theirs I
don't really give a [ __ ] what people
think honestly my favorite question is
Oh where's her mother like where's your
dad
[Music]
thank you so much for watching that
episode guys that was one of our most
requested episodes teen dad so I hope
you enjoyed go to human good la comm and
get this awesome apparel as always guys
thank you so much for watching make sure
to comment below like subscribe pose on
Instagram where all the magic happens
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching